now you've been hearing everywhere else
about the virus and the latest numbers
and the medical response but I want to
focus tonight on what I think is an even
bigger crisis and that is the economic
social and above all human cost of the
total shutdown policy no one should
question the seriousness of this virus
and especially as I said last week the
need to avoid so many hospitalizations
at the same time that our medical system
can't cope the chosen strategy is social
distancing and right now that involves
extreme measures to shut down daily life
but there is a huge gap between sensible
social distancing and the total shutdown
spreading across the country just as the
spread of coronavirus creates a curve of
the number of people infected this
economic shutdown is creating a curve of
the numbers of people affected losing
their jobs their homes their businesses
I'm not sure that the people on TV have
grasped how serious this is to the
extent they're focusing on it at all
they're using completely the wrong frame
of reference they talk about a recession
like the one we had in 2008 what planet
are they on we've never seen this before
a total self-imposed shutdown of the
economy businesses large medium and
small will lose all their revenue not a
slight reduction or even a steep
reduction like in a recession but all of
it gone no income nothing potentially
for months we're told unless we change
course the best case is the worst
recession since the Second World War the
moderate scenario is that it's on a par
with the great depression the worst case
scenario where this shutdown continues
for months is even worse than the Great
Depression
we hear about a v-shaped curve a
dramatic fall and a quick bounce-back
maybe but if the V is as deep as the
Grand Canyon that is a hell of a climb
in Washington today the Senate failed to
advance the latest coronavirus relief
package so negotiations will continue on
what's looking to be a two trillion
dollar stimulus plan let's talk about
that plan
and as we do let's remind ourselves what
this is all about men and women across
America who have risked everything
worked every hour to follow their dreams
and build a business local businesses
there are not just economic units but
the lifeblood of a community most of the
people in Congress most of the talking
heads on TV they've never started a
business and don't understand business I
have and I do so what I'm about to say
comes not just from my perspective as
someone who's run policy at the heart of
a large government but someone who's run
a small business a number of them
actually including one a restaurant that
was at the heart of its community
President Trump gets this - he
understands business he loves
entrepreneurs he loves America's small
businesses and farmers and all the
workers who rely on them for a living
and to support their families so this
economic curve we're about to take a
nosedive on it is not just about money
it's about the heart and soul of this
country in the hours ahead let's make
sure the Congressional stimulus package
doesn't miss the target
part of it will be spent sending a
cheque to every American on April the
6th and another on May the 18th but by
April the 6th hundreds of thousands of
businesses will have closed and millions
of people will be unemployed worse it
will be those with the most precarious
lives least able to cope by May my god
millions of businesses will go under and
tens of millions will be unemployed look
more money is always welcome for
hard-pressed Americans but this is not
about stimulus it's about survival and
the whole sender check scheme
misunderstands why someone goes under or
not if you're a small business you have
bills to pay right now not in April or
May now payroll rent but you have no
revenue thanks to the government's total
shutdown you have to let people go so
then they don't have income to pay their
rent or their mortgage and before you
know it you have mass unemployment and
families on the streets millions of
viable businesses murdered by the
government the second part of the
current congressional plan a small
business loan scheme Larry Kudlow who
you'll see later too
on this show he says it can work quickly
but even the help that's supposed to be
there right now doesn't work a friend of
mine tried to use the Small Business
Administration emergency grant program
this week the website was wrong that
details were wrong it is a total mess
businesses are folding today tomorrow
Tuesday who's got time to fill out forms
send them into some giant bureaucracy
wait for an answer even if it's yes then
find yourself saddled by crippling loans
for years and don't get me started on
the third part of the so-called stimulus
plan bailouts for big business I think
there is a quicker and simpler way to
flatten the economic curve businesses
have insurance policies to cover them
for loss of revenue the problem is a
pandemic isn't covered but if the
government stood behind the insurance
companies and said we'll indemnify you
for any coronavirus payouts then the
insurance companies could be getting
money to businesses straight away
covering their revenues so they can stay
afloat and keep people employed we can
incentivize insurance companies to do it
quickly by the way quickly means within
seven days not April on top of that
announced a nationwide policy of no
evictions or foreclosures residential or
commercial of course this would all cost
a vast amount of money which they seem
to be spending like water it went from
one trillion turd to in a couple of days
quite frankly if they keep up the
shutdowns till the end of May they'll
need five trillion if it's till August
twelve trillion this is an inconceivable
amount of public money it amounts to a
total government takeover of the economy
are we ready for that can we afford that
well even if we can't at least let's
spend the money we can afford in ways
that actually save our businesses but
there's a much better way to flatten the
economic curve dr foul she says he's
fine overreacting I like it when people
are thinking I'm overreacting because
that means we're doing it just right
well that's easy for him to say he'll
still have a job
at the end of this whatever happens our
ruling class and their TV mouthpieces
whipping up fear over this virus they
can afford an indefinite shutdown
working Americans can't they'll be
crushed by it you know that famous
phrase the cure is worse than the
disease that is exactly the territory we
are hurtling towards you think is just a
corona virus that kills people this
total economic shutdown will kill people
a UK study calculated that a hundred and
thirty thousand people died avoid ibly
from austerity there between 2012 and
2017 the years of austerity for America
to pay the cost of this shutdown will be
worse adjusting for the size of our
economy it's over a million deaths but
the family thrown out of their home the
mom gets sick the kids are orphans her
death won't be counted the dad who's
been out of work for 30 years and
finally got a job last month and now
he's back on the scrap heap and turning
back to drink and drugs his death won't
show up in a neat little box on cable
news poverty kills despair kills this
shutdown is deadly the president
announced a 15-day plan to beat the
virus after that let's say right we came
together to slow the spread now let's
come together to protect the vulnerable
get the ventilators get the beds get the
equipment fry heroic nurses and doctors
keep the ban on large gatherings but
stop the total shutdown for everyone and
start the total protection of the
elderly and those most likely to need
hospitalization don't turn a public
health crisis into America's worst
catastrophe save small business flatten
the curve not the economy and do it
before it's too late